so nice to have you here and
congratulations you won this
championship belt which they brought out
I'm only assuming this is mine now it's
a gift that is a great from me to you
now what was it like to put this on for
the first time I know you've worked hard
your whole life and then too it just
looks so funny to hold it up against it
matches your hair yeah it does yeah so
you saw actually the clip there when I'm
not the guy out yeah it helps that I
wasn't big the biggest fan of that guy
so that helped so that suit you mentally
hate the person you're high I don't need
to hate anybody I enjoy doing what I do
but still when is it kind of a smoke
break yeah it definitely helps you jabs
can I just remind you just whispered
into a microphone on television when
he's kind of a smug I'm sure that helps
you get in the game and you've been
training hard all your life obviously
this is something you started a young
age yeah that's right I started martial
arts when I was eight years old oh my
god 38 announce the 38 that's right 30
years yeah yeah we're getting major more
time at school yeah
you